así
en esta lección exploraremos el
maravilloso mundo del software de
articulación
para construir un personaje en pixar
empezamos con un paquete de modelado
estos constan de una serie de dibujos de
esculturas de arcilla llamadas maquetas
que sirven de guía para modelar el
personaje para los personajes más
importantes puede haber muchos dibujos y
para los que son menos importantes puede
bastar con un garabato en una servilleta
a partir de estos elementos podemos
construir un modelo en la computadora
espero que hayas disfrutado de articular
la cara del muñeco de nieve en la
lección 1 en esta lección crearás tu
personaje de una manera similar a como
pixar construye un muñeco de nieve para
el cortometraje knick knack antes de
empezar el articulador se reunirá con un
animador para discutir qué tipo de
controles son necesarios un personaje
como el soldado de 'toy story' estará
hecho de plástico por lo que sus
movimientos serán muy rígidos en
contraste una serpiente de goma sería
bastante flexible trabajar conforme a la
esencia de los materiales genera
credibilidad articulador y animador
colaboran de cerca en todo el proceso de
articulación para asegurar que el
animador tenga todos los controles
necesarios para hacer que el personaje
cobre vida y actúe el animador hará
varias pruebas como con calistenia para
probar una gama de alternativas de
articulación la prueba final suele
consistir en una escena actuada
completamente en esta lección escribirás
código para diseñar tu modelo luego
articular a tu modelo con las funciones
de formador que aprendiste en la
elección anterior empezaras por dibujar
formas básicas luego combinas las formas
para hacer personajes
entonces construyes las funciones de de
formador para trasladarle escalar y
rotar y por último conectas todo junto
en un paso extra te enseñaremos cómo
animar tus modelos pero primero pensemos
sobre lo que estamos haciendo todos los
modelos tienen una cosa en común desde
la perspectiva de la computadora un
modelo solo es una colección de formas
individuales cada forma se almacenará en
la computadora como un objeto
para crear la forma de un círculo
pondremos en el objeto todos los datos
que necesitará la computadora para crear
esa forma en este ejercicio de
calentamiento crearás un círculo para el
cuerpo del muñeco de nieve si eres
novato en la programación tenemos un
breve repaso sobre este tema su
increíble